all right your most accurate weather now  forecast with sherry off we start with a  great look across the resort corridor  and it looks beautiful but believe it or  not there have been a couple of reports  of  snowflakes in las vegas even the  official temperature is 40.  i was talking with the men and women out  at the national weather service  and there's a combination of factors  that have made it possible for what  little moisture there is in the air to  show up as snowflakes  it's not going to stick it's not going  to be measurable and it's one of those  deals where if you blink  you might miss it but again thanks to  photographer chad graves out by umc near  downtown las vegas with a couple of  snowflakes this morning